[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and it's time to get schwifty as we're
breaking down another episode of rick
and morty
the fourth entry for season five is now
here and there's a lot of easter eggs
hidden details and things you missed in
it that we're going to be going over in
this video
now we start off with morty in this
stupid horse hospital
waiting for his mother to finish up so
that she can go see the latest piece of
marvel [ __ ]
that he and his friends are always
[ __ ] over sight engine i do have some
black widow videos on the channel
that are worth [ __ ] over god damn now
speaking of something that
is worth [ __ ] over morty comes across
skews the pun a breeding mount and he
ends up using it as a tool to do
what teenage boys do eight times a day
sometimes when i was in my prime but
moving on that there's some cool little
details in here
now the hospital is called saint equus
which is latin for horse
this location appeared in the pilot
episode and as it's rick and morty
there was a dark sense of humor to its
introduction we could see a horse being
pulled in
and then a pool of blood the next time
we saw it i did go over this scene a
number of times to see if there was
anything connected to the horse being
pulled out
and the rags that beth tossed into the
bin however i couldn't quite spot
anything but if you notice something
then let me know below
however horse does give birth to ricks
maybe later on
so i think maybe it's sort of setting
that up and again it's like poetry they
rhyme
now cut to one week later and we see
morty sunbathing on the rooftop of his
home
in the wake of the breakup from
planetina he's clearly found something
else to occupy him
and he's been a dirty little dog we see
rick rolling in the sperm container
which
morty spent the last seven days filling
up and it turns out that rick wants to
use it to wipe out some cannibalistic
horse people
known as chud this is actually a note of
the film chud
which was released in 1984. church stood
for cannibalistic humanoid underground
dwellers
but here it's been changed up to horse
people to die mooring with a theme of
horse sperm
babies and so on rick also pays lip
service to the phrase measure twice cut
once
which actually pulls from carpentry it
is thought that if you didn't measure a
piece of wood correctly before cutting
it
that it'll waste not only time but
resources too
however here it's being used for
scientific purposes
rick starts to test the sperm even
though morty clearly doesn't want him to
and this creates some giant monsters
intent on killing everyone they come
across
hey come across i know i used that jog
before yeah but
it's it's one of the best i've got now
there's several nods to other monsters
in their design
and i got a lot of flashes to a number
of properties the first of these is of
course chewed
but i think there's also nuts to a quiet
place the monsters attack and destroy
cars much like how they do
and even the introduction of the scene
comes up with a passage of time
much like how that movie 2 shows a
number of days on screen when carrying
out some of its jumps
there's also attack of the killer
tomatoes as well as little shop of
horrors
which i think the monsters look very
similar to in that we discovered that a
plant needed human blood to survive
and this had some big repercussions on
it much in the same way that more east
dna creates some issues too
there's also independence day and the
episode itself is called
rick dependent spray which yeah
we know exactly what was spraying there
now i love how there's also this
undercurrent that the entire thing could
be set
up by rick just to get morty to admit
what he's been doing with the breeding
mount
and it isn't the first time he's gone
above and beyond to embarrass the boy
anyway we cutted the titles and if
you've been enjoying the video so far
then i'd massively appreciate the thumbs
up
also don't forget to subscribe as we do
breakdowns of the show every week
and they're always worth coming back for
right i'll stop with that now i promise
you
i'll try and make the video good from
this point out now we come to the
sanchez and smith family driving through
america
in a scene that's very reminiscent to
the one take car scene from steven
spielberg's war of the worlds
eventually they're swamped and one of
the space span pulls the roof off the
top of the car
which could be a naughty jurassic park
when the t-rex tried to do the same
thing
they're saved by the president's men who
take rick in and this idea of our
characters being brought in with the
president
of course ties in with independence day
in which a similar sort of thing
happened
rick tells morty he's gonna have to lie
about where the sperm came from and the
creative team at the very end of the
episode discussed how this entire entry
is based around the idea of lies we see
this repeated in several characters
with morty eventually learning to tell
the truth even if something is
embarrassing for someone
this of course ties in with him being
embarrassed about the breeding mount
and i love the little throw away line
where the president wonders how big of a
d they'd have to be for there to be
space spoon is big
and summer says same page club rick does
the usual monologue that we get in
horror movies
where he talks about our ancient myths
and legends and how
they may all actually be tied to space
sperm the president believes that either
rick or the church caused it
but morty lies for his grandfather which
leads to the death of several people
including blazin the president did
believe that morty was a straight
shooter
and i are you having that now they bring
in the world's leading scientist on
sperm
professor shabubu he has wet splashes up
his tie
and on his suit jacket and i also think
that that might be tissues in his pocket
but
that might just be me yeah with my dirty
mind
now after figuring out the spin i've
gone to america's vagina
they bring in a space sperm to study it
and this design looks slightly based on
the cage scene from starship troopers
mori shoots it after saying it was armed
and the president believes him because
apparently he never lies namori decides
that they need to be the ones to deal
with it
and they head out with some male marines
as the president doesn't really believe
that women are useful
however the space sperm are led by a
queen and this is of course a little nod
to aliens
and how the xenomorphs were led by one
these alien easter eggs reoccur with the
marines that go on a mission with them
and we also get ties to predator when
the survivors of the group land in the
forest
and have to duke it out with the space
boom in the woods i think it's pretty
obvious that blazing is also based on
katana from the suicide squad
and though rick initially thinks he's a
badass he goes out hilariously whilst
exposing that he wears his wife's thongs
and also carries around a swimsuit cover
with her on it that he has sex with
now the plane is shot down by a catapult
so sorry trebuchet
but just before this we see rick's
safety tentacles which are of course
based on dr octopus's arms
after coming up with a plan that looks
like tic-tac-toe the space sperm attack
and morty ends up saving one of them
called sticky who ends up impregnating
his sister's egg
and creating an incest space baby yeah
it gets really weird
now back with the president summer comes
up with a plan but it's completely
overlooked
and instead it's suggested by shibu who
gets a nobel prize for it
cut back to rick morty and blazen as
they head into the sperm cave
this is very much playing on the story
trope first brought to the mainstream by
joseph campbell
he came up with the notion of the hero's
journey which discusses how someone must
travel into the abyss to discover new
things about themselves
it's also often referred to as the belly
of the beast and it's popped up in a
number of movies
especially the early ones that this
episode is based upon
blaisen decides to sacrifice himself but
it goes to hell
and all he does is impale impale himself
with his sword now he tells morty to
find his wife
and say that he wasn't wearing her thong
which she's disgusted over
at the end the space sperm close in on
them but when it looks like everything
is lost the queen arrives and captures
them
i feel like the sperm queen's design is
based slightly off the alien from
species
with elements of the borg queen also
thrown in there for good measure
they want to create their army using a
breeding mount and it's finally revealed
that morty was behind it all
rick is frozen in a statuesque pose and
he refers to himself as [ __ ] solo
which is of course a nod to when han
solo was frozen in carbonite during the
empire strikes back
the sperm are furious because their
father has sent so many of them into
socks
and when it looks like it's all over
sticky arrives and saves them
though it looks like he might not be
able to beat the queen because they
didn't bring a woman that kickboxes
he uses his second tail to bring them
down in an underdog move
unfortunately the eggplant is still
going ahead and the sperm head to las
vegas which is the location of several
alien invasion films
and also where the movie army of the
dead was set just before they can fully
warn them it should arrive
and i love how rick says incest baby and
one of the gods just says
what who told you that now back in vegas
shibu throws himself of a building in
order to escape having to come up with a
plan
it should take them in and morty says he
can't change his nature
which rick rebuffs by saying he's not a
scorpion in an overhaul fable
this is playing on the story of the
scorpion and the frog which is a
metaphor that talks about the time the
two animals were trying to cross a river
together
the frog didn't want to at first because
the scorpion could sting it
however the scorpion said that this
would kill it as well so it could be
trusted
but halfway across the river it stung
the frog anyway because that's part of
its nature
he also talks about robert downey jr and
what the actor was like in the 90s
before he got the pot of iron man
he said that he was waking up in bushes
and this actually happened to him
downey also decided to go sober after he
had a burger king cheeseburger
and it disgusted him so much that it
completely made him change
this was referenced in iron man when
upon returning from the cave
the first thing that he got was a
cheeseburger now they should want to
boil rick and morty alive
but princess ponier comes forth and
admits that the former is the father of
her child
back in vegas the president covers a
giant wall in spermicide
which is a lubrication that kills sperm
before they manage to reach the egg
we're also introduced to the amazing
jonathan a comedian
and magician who has performed in vegas
several times
the sperm managed to break through the
wall by having one go in as a kamikaze
bomber
which is not the lord of the rings the
two towers when urokai managed to blow
the wall at helm's deep in a similar way
rick ends the war with the chud and they
unite with the humans to take down the
sperm
as beth and summer fly through the city
on the back of some sperm
we can also see a sign that says the
sultan of swoon which is what frank
sinatra
was sometimes referred to as the
creative team also said that this scene
was another jumanji and the stampede
from that
and it's basically all of the sperm
trying to swim towards the egg
join with the forces of cirque du soleil
and amazing jonathan the turd managed to
defeat the sperm until all that remains
is the sperm queen and sticky
sticky kills the queen and goes into the
egg and summer goes to shoot it but the
president stops this because it's an
election year
this is of course playing on the notion
that abortion often comes up during
elections
and it often leads to a very heated
debate the pyramid shoots into space
and blazon's wife arrives to ask if he
was wearing her thong
she says she hopes he was wearing it and
tells morty to be honest
but this is a lie rick hooks up once
more with ponieta
before she gives birth to their child
and she returns to her kingdom
the episode ends with impressing that
that was easy button and we could have
the post-credits scene to see morty's
baby flowing in space
this is a play on 2001 a space odyssey
in which an astronaut evolved to become
the next stage of human life and he
returned to earth
the astronaut says he thinks it's his
conscious after abandoning his family
and this is sometimes used as an
interpretation of the final scene of a
space odyssey
as the astronaut watches himself age
alone he really wished that he could get
a chance to come
home and all these come puns and it's
still
not coming home i'm sorry guys you know
too soon and uh yeah i'm a bit gutted
that closes out the episode and as for
my thoughts on it i think this is
probably the worst of the four
it's getting a lot of hate on reddit but
i still think it had some funny moments
it was just one of those weird episodes
like there are some theories that each
episode so far has been a decoy family
and that's purely because the space bet
thing hasn't been connected to anything
that's happened so far
there's also elements like the portal
gun which hasn't shown up at all
and rick has been drinking some of the
episodes and not others
now let me know what you think below but
yeah one of the weaker episodes i think
but overall i still think this season so
far has been pretty good
now as a thank you for for dropping a
comment you'll be entered into a
competition on the 30th of july
in which we're giving away three mcu box
sets all you have to do to be on the
chance to win
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode you pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month
and the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so that's you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
loki episode 5
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over the whole thing from top to
bottom and it's probably one of our best
breakdowns ever
so definitely go watch it after this
without the way thank you for singing
through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace